that the worst of all of our political
leaders during covid was the evil snake
person the lizard man himself Gavin
Newsom and Gavin Newsom is prepping
right now to run for president of the
United States when they pushed Joe Biden
aside that is that is a fact I don't
think that's conjecture or anything else
it is obviously happening it's obviously
in the works so he was on Meet the Press
yesterday uh and Chuck Todd asked him
about his covid response during covet
um you you were pretty strict with the
lockdowns here
and uh it was an interesting piece in
Harpers that sort of
was critic critical of your decisions
from this perspective
you found a way to allow the motion
picture industry and so in the in the
sort of the movie industry to get back
to work but she didn't allow people to
grieve together at funerals or at
churches and that it sort of and that
this may be why there's such a polarized
disconnect what what you prioritize
right this is this anger between the
populace and the elite supposedly here
you prioritize this industry
but
you you know you were tougher on those
that just wanted to go worship what do
you say to that Chris I think there's a
lot of humility and we didn't know we
didn't know and it was hardly I uh it
was we collectively I think all of us in
terms of our Collective wisdom we've
evolved we didn't know we didn't know
we're experts in hindsight we're all
Geniuses but think about what we
probably what you ended up collectively
prioritizing you're prioritizing
industry
one specific one but then didn't
prioritize maybe once it whose maybe
values you didn't connect with I don't
think it's a binary there was iterations
within that theme
Gavin Newsom is the devil he is a truly
evil like there is no other way to
describe it even now he can't fully
apologize now Donald Trump can either
right but Donald Trump is not known for
humility Democrats are supposed to be
nice aren't they what what an evil
now I want to thank him
actually because because of him I moved
my family in two companies and all the
people in this room to the free state of
Florida and our lives were all
flourishing but he has demolished that
state he kept his Winery open he has a
40-acre winery up by Napa he managed to
keep that open while he kept other
wineries closed he locked people in
their houses while he was having dinner
at French Laundry one of the most
expensive restaurants in the United
States with with lobbyists
he is absolutely evil he can't show
Contrition and he can't even put it on
his looks he can't even put it on
himself he's the governor oh it wasn't I
it was we our Collective wisdom well why
did I know plenty of people that did not
want to get vaxed and that didn't want
to lose their minds and go crazy and I
personally know because I met them at
protests against him people most of whom
were Democrats they were just Democrats
who were mugged by reality who all
become conservatives who who now hate
him and actively were working to get him
recalled and everything else these were
not extremists these were people who
just wanted to live their lives
thank you foreign